what's coming from my heart right now is  maybe you're watching this and saying  hmm maybe I need to hench you know if  you work from eating p.m. to 4:00 in the  morning well your dreams come true no  you might not be good enough you might  have not picked the right product but  are we living in a world in 2012 that's  so much better than your parents and  grandparents and great-grandparents  generation because it [ __ ] like me  can make videos when I'm 30,000 [ __ ]  feet in the air yes and because of that  and because of those opportunities  because we're networked in a way we've  never seen before because sending an  email to 100 people and one will answer  and give you a shot matters because of  that opportunity because the 2012 I beg  you I beg you to take a shot